a racist description of mexican
immigrants marked donald trump's
dramatic entrance to the presidential
race in 2016.
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime
they're rapists he then vowed to build a
border wall
we're going to build the wall mexico is
going to pay for the wall
helping to attract a base of mostly
white working-class supporters
whose fears of america's growing
diversity contributed to trump's win
from this day forward it's going to be
only america first
america first the wall trump built
though
fell far short of what he promised these
prototypes never advanced past the
testing phase
instead trump built 730 kilometers of
fencing mostly to replace older sections
and mexico didn't pay a penny of the 15
billion dollar price tag
that money is coming from american
taxpayers after trump
shut down the government for 35 days
then declared a national emergency to
commandeer some of the funding
still in the final days of his
presidency trump returned to his
so-called wall
to tout it as a win i think when you see
what
it does and how it's so important for
our country
nobody is going to be touching it border
arrests plunged during trump's first
three months in office
but then caravans of migrant families
began traveling north from central
america
claiming to flee gang violence by the
summer of trump's second year in the
white house
unauthorized border crossings reached a
13-year high
of more than 130 thousand a month it was
in the midst of that surge
that came trump's family separation
policy
federal agents took more than 4 thousand
children from their parents at the
border
a practice that drew widespread
condemnation
a judge quickly ordered the policy to
end saying children were suffering
irreparable harm and must be returned to
their families
but even today some 500 kids remain
separated in its haste to do trump's
will
the u.s government had lost track of
their parents
it's not as if the us government
collected mailing addresses
for them when they deported them we
really don't know where they
are which is why there's more than 500
families
who are still separated another
controversial border policy
trump's treatment of asylum seekers in
2019 the u.s government stopped giving
them conditional entrance into the
country
now some 60 000 asylum seekers have been
forced
to wait in mexico for a turn to see a
u.s judge
that coupled with new coveted
restrictions slowed unauthorized border
crossings to a trickle last spring
but now the numbers are rising anew it's
likely that people are
have renewed hope for how the southern
border will operate with the new
incoming president trump's legacy on
immigration
is still to be determined by the u.s
supreme court
which dealt him a blow when it had ruled
earlier that an obama-era program
protecting young undocumented immigrants
could remain
now a new panel of justices including
three trump appointees
in the coming months will hear
challenges to trump's border policies
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington